plus aucun train de marchandises ne
transite en lituanie entre la russie et
kaliningrad loin d'être anecdotique
cette mesure a suscité la colère de
moscou car cette ligne ferroviaire et la
plus directe pour approvisionner ce
territoire russe située entre la
lituanie et la pologne
bien sûr la russie réagir à de tels
actes hostiles des mesures appropriées
sont en train d'être élaboré au niveau
interministériel et seront adoptées
prochainement elles auront de sérieuses
conséquences négatives pour la
population de la lituanie moscou évoque
un blocus de son côté le gouvernement
lituanien sûr qu'il ne s'agit là que de
l'application des sanctions européennes
suite à l'invasion russe en ukraine
il n'y a aucun blocus de kaliningrad
c'est simplement que depuis le week-end
dernier des mesures sont entrées en
vigueur sur certains des biens inclus
dans le paquet de sanctions
la lituanie n'a aucun intérêt à mettre
de l'huile sur le feu mais il y à des
sanctions et elles doivent être
appliquées d'après les autorités russes
entre quarante et cinquante pour cent
des marchandises transportées pourraient
être soumises aux restrictions
cela concerne les matériaux de
construction mais aussi le charbon ou
encore les ordinateurs et les téléphones
portables
les travaux de construction vont devoir
s'arrêter je pense notamment à la
rénovation des routes tous ne fera
qu'empirer je pense que beaucoup de gens
vont perdre leur emploi il n'y a pas
d'autre option
le gouverneur de kaliningrad a annoncé
que les marchandises soumises aux
restrictions seraient acheminées par
voie maritime d'ici la semaine prochaine
voilà et puis vous le savez aussi la
russie a coupé une partie du gaz sur le
territoire européen
c'est une attaque dit berlin à l'instant